hey everyone so
um I'm gonna introduce uh Dr Abigail
person who is an associate professor and
co-director of the Neuroscience program
at the University of Colorado School of
Medicine
she's an expert in understanding the
computations in the cerebellum and its
role in smooth and precise movement Dr
person has been awarded the butcher
Foundation web warning biomedical
research award and the Esther a and
Joseph klingelstein fund award in the
neurosciences please welcome please
welcome her
thank you
all right well it's a delight to be here
um seeing Heroes of the field in every
direction
um and so I want I really want to thank
you Lynn Nita for the invitation it
means a lot so with that um I heard that
MIT is not a place um for um for
compliments and so I'm going to start
with an image of Mount Harvard not not
to create like a Crosstown rivalry or
anything but just to kind of you know
introduce you to my home state I've been
giving a lot of Zoom talks and since I
don't go there I bring myself to other
people but this hasn't yet changed so
I present to you mount Harvard now the
reason I'm showing you this isn't really
just because I'm from Colorado but
because if we were to gaze up onto one
of these snow fields we might see a
creature like this this mountain goat is
in fact demonstrating
um a kind of precise action which really
motivates many of the questions in my
lab so you can see that it's really
reaching for its next foothold here not
unlike this now famous climber Alex
Honnold who's reaching for his next hand
hold on his certifiably insane ropless
Ascent of El Capitan in California so I
hope you can appreciate that the
Precision of movement is a life or death
scenario for these creatures one
imprecise movement could lead to the
death of these animals and
um and so we're very interested in how
the brain actually mediates these kinds
of behaviors now it turns out that Alex
Honnold has actually had his brain
scanned and there's something wrong
evidently with his amygdala but I would
argue that there's absolutely nothing
wrong with his cerebellum and the reason
that I can make that speculation is that
we've known for over a hundred years
really starting with the work of a
British physician named Gordon Holmes
who studied World War one uh veterans
who ha who suffered fairly localized
cerebellar lesions to this man who has a
unilateral cerebellar lesion
that the cerebellum is critical for
precise reaching movements so I'm going
to show you this this movie this man's
going to reach to his nose with his
unaffected limb and then he's going to
reach to his nose with his affected Limb
and you'll easily see the kind of motor
deficit that characterizes cerebellar
damage
so that's the good nose or that's the
good arm and this is the bad arm so with
the good arm he precisely slows to touch
his nose with the bad arm he oscillates
right around that end point
so these oscillations which I'll show
you one more time
have
um resonance with all kinds of control
theory that I think many Engineers are
very familiar with with Control Systems
so the problem is that when sensory
feedback is delayed relative to the
output of the system that there's
naturally oscillations that emerge so
the way I often describe this with
reaching movements is if you were to
merely use your visual system to reach
for a particular glass of water or
something the visual information would
be way out of date by the time your fast
reach brought your limb to that Target
and you'd overshoot the target then you
would over correct and you would
overshoot and so that's essentially what
people hypothesize these oscillations
around endpoints are in patients with
cerebellar damage
and so it suggests that the cerebellum
may be Computing some kind of
anticipatory control that that sort of
obviates this problem in the nervous
system this slow sensory feedback
problem
so this is kind of the working framework
that we have in the lab is that the
cerebellum may be generating some kind
of anticipatory control and there's a
lot of work that tries to map the um
sort of nature of information that
enters the cerebellum through the mossy
fibers into the cerebellum that sort of
takes two flavors either sensory
information or motor information this
ends up providing a very rich
spatiotemporal context for every
movement that's represented in the
granule sole layer which then projects
into the purkinje cell layer the
purkinje neurons are the sort of
learning workhorses of the cerebellum
and there are many theories about what
they compute I'm going to sort of skip
over all of the debate and just call it
an internal model it's some kind of
representation of the body that's
localized to whatever sort of effector
we're talking about
those purkinje neurons are inhibitory
projection neurons they project down to
the output structures of the cerebellum
which are the cerebellar nuclei the
cerebellar nuclei then distribute the
output computation of the cerebellum to
many different areas and that is sort of
modular depending on what cerebellar
nucleus we're talking about along this
medial to lateral dimension
okay so this is this theory that we have
that that we get to work with but when
we started the lab the evidence for any
kind of feed forward control coming out
of the cerebellum was very marginal and
so we wanted to know where do we look
for a evidence of feed forward
anticipatory control
well we really relied on data sets that
had been generated over the years
investigating limb movements in a
variety of creatures including cats
monkeys and mice and several papers
including
um work from Claude getz's lab as well
as work from Albert Chen's lab
identified a particular output structure
the anterior interposed nucleus as being
critical for limb movements
um so they would use either mucumolin
activation or genetic lesions of output
neurons and found that those kinds of
inactivation schemes recapitulated the
um the phenomenon of dysmetria
and so this gave us a place to look but
no by no means really isolated a
anticipatory control
um signature because these long-term
inactivations don't distinguish between
problems in motor planning or or
identify control policies and so that's
really where we began when we wanted to
sort of interrogate this idea
so the first work I'm going to show you
is all work from a fantastic graduate
student lab at Becker
he combined a real-time
three-dimensional limb tracking with
electrophysiology and optogenetics to
address this question of what is the
interposed nucleus do to control
reaching movements and so he um used a
motion capture system so that we could
essentially get real-time readout of
movement kinematics and we use a mouse
model for for many of the obvious
reasons
um and it's nice because the these
reaching movements are fairly discreet
so we can look at many of them mice will
readily engage in this task and we had
this place to look for some kind of
cerebellar control
so the first observation we made using
electrophysiological recordings from the
interposed nucleus is that neurons in
the interposed nucleus are modulated
during reach so you can see an example
neuron here where here we've aligned
neural activity to the reach onset and
you can see that the the cells are
modulated
however this modulation is really rather
sloppy from trial to trial as I I think
you can appreciate however if we simply
align the neural data to the endpoint of
reaches we find that the neural activity
is in fact much more sharply
regulated and so this was interesting to
us because as you might recall from the
video its movement endpoints that seem
to be preferentially disturbed in
patients with cerebellar damage indeed
we saw this kind of endpoint modulation
in many neurons within the interposed
nucleus by by no means all of the
neurons but many of these cells showed
this kind of um endpoint uh related
activity which you can see sort of
happens right during this decelerative
phase of the reaching movement
and so the natural question that we
asked is is this activity causal for
limb control so to address this question
we we introduced channel rhodopsin to
the output neurons of the of the
cerebellar nuclei within the anterior
interposed nucleus
um implant an optical fiber over intake
and then used closed loop optogenetic
stimulation just during reach on
randomized 25 percent of reaches and
asks what's the kinematic consequence of
this of this perturbation
so um this is a short stimulus you'll
see it displayed up in the top and it's
Illustrated here as well so here's a
mouse
it's stimulated doesn't get the pellet
sometimes they don't get the pellet
however so um let's look at many reaches
so this illustration shows unstimulated
reaches in Orange and stimulated reaches
in blue the point of the 50 millisecond
stimulation stimulus train is shown here
and then I pull down stills from this
movie down here and so what you can see
is early in the reach these reaches are
indistinguishable as you would expect
but right after the stimulation you can
see that the stimulated reaches are not
as far out and they're not as far up and
then there's only a late phase
correction and so if we looked at these
reaches in sort of outward velocity
space we'd find that
um the the outward velocity slows
rapidly
um in response to stimulation okay and
the upshot here is that these reaches
end up hypometric so the mouse is not
reaching as far in response to this
stimulation
um so I am going to skip a bunch of data
but we can we can show that modulating
the strength of optogenetic stimulation
modulates the strength of the kinematic
effect and that we can deliver this
stimulation at any point in reach and
always see this reduction in outward
velocity
so the obvious question then if we want
to interpret the activity that we
observed in the interposed nucleus as
causal for deceleration is that we
should be able to to reduce activity in
that structure and see the opposite
effect and so we did this experiment
where we we introduced Arch into the
interposed nucleus what we found is
indeed a consistent increase in all nine
animals that we tested this in in the
outward velocity so here we're we're
sort of under some biomechanical
constraints of the the sort of length of
the limb we see this very consistent
increase in outward velocity during the
arch inactivation of the nucleus and uh
and concomitant overshooting of the of
the reach endpoint
so these data summarize give us this
idea that this activity in the
interposed nucleus acts as some kind of
a velocity dial to regulate limb
kinematics
but there are a lot of potential
interpretations of these data so for
example we know that activity from the
motor cortex is critical for driving
these movements this is in my beautiful
work done by Adam Hampton's group where
they've inactivated motor cortex during
reach and that halts the movement
entirely
so what is this um structure the
cerebellum doing to these putative
commands from motor cortex
so our data are consistent with at least
two models the first is that maybe this
activity from cerebellum is acting like
something like a break or a gain
controller so if you imagine some sort
of um on unfettered command from cortex
generating a movement with a particular
outward and upward velocity and then we
stimulate the cerebellum and that's
reduced so that's one possibility an
equally tenable possibility is that
there's some kind of a directional
command that's in the opposite direction
that is being added to this control
signal from motor cortex
so these two um these two possibilities
are interesting because they make
distinguishable hypotheses about what
should happen if we stimulate on Return
of the movement so if we stimulate on
return and we are activating or reducing
the gain of that that uh that command or
we're just breaking the limb then we
should show that the limb will slow down
uh in response to that stimulation
alternatively if we're at introducing
sort of a return uh Vector of command we
should actually speed the limb up if we
stimulate on return
so we perform this experiment and our
data are consistent with this model
because when we stimulate in the
negative velocity domain we find that
the limb actually goes faster in the
return Direction
so these data are
um support the view that there is some
kind of a summation of directional
control vectors that are mediating the
limb movements in this in this paradigm
so we wanted to return to the neural
data and ask a little bit of a deeper
question about refinement of movement by
the cerebellum so um we sorted reaches
by the firing rates that were issued by
the interposed nucleus during a
particular reach and separated those
into deciles which are color coded here
so the reaches um that had the highest
firing rate not surprisingly what I've
already shown you decelerated the
fastest and those with the lowest firing
rates decelerated the slowest this is
also consistent with other
linear correlation analyzes that we did
but why should we expect trial by trial
variability in the firing rates to
happen at all so to address this we went
back in time from the um Epoch that
we're analyzing for firing rates here
and looked at the peak velocity of the
reaches and we found that reaches that
decelerated the fastest and had the
highest firing rates also had the
highest peak velocities and reaches that
decelerated the slowest and had the
lowest uh firing rates also had the
lowest Peak velocities
okay so this gets a little bit wobbly so
but the upshot is if that is that the
end points regardless of this initial
kinematic variability
were stable so the if the animal reached
slowly and it would decelerate slowly
and it would end on Target and if it
reached very fast it would decelerate
very quickly and end on Target and so
the model that we propose is that this
activity that's regulated on a reach by
reach basis in the interposed nucleus is
accommodating a deceleration that allows
the limb to end on target
and we can illustrate that if you did
not have this kind of scaled activity
from the inner pose that reaches that
started out very slow and had an average
rate of deceleration would end
hypometric so they would slow down
essentially too fast for a particular
end point conversely reaches that start
out very fast and do not decelerate fast
enough would end up hypermetric with the
average deceleration profile so by
regulating this late phase kinematic
feature the cerebellum May improve the
Precision of movements
so that's kind of the model that we had
going where we have this kind of peak
velocity that scales activity in the
interposed nucleus to regulate the
decelerative phase of the reaching
movement and so the next question that
we that we um uh wanted to address is
how this computation might actually be
made
um and so to to address this we we made
the very not controversial decision to
look at the purkinje neurons which are
the of course the major driver to the
interposed nucleus
um and so another very talented student
in the lab Dylan Callum
um ended up targeting
um his neural recordings to us a part of
the cerebellar cortex that had
previously been identified by Tom Otis's
lab as as controlling or at least
influencing forelim movements in mice
um and so indeed when he um recorded in
this region he found many Perkin neurons
that modulate their activity around the
time of reach and so he could look at
entire populations of these cells and
find that you know there were cells that
increased their firing rate around the
time of reach and souls that decrease
their firing rate around the reach I
should say that these are all high
firing rate cells many of them have
complex spikes and that's how we're
identifying them as purkinje cells so if
we look at population psths of these two
populations these increasers and
decreasers if you will we find that
they're practically mirror images of the
two
and for a very long time we were
spending a lot of time doing all kinds
of sophisticated regression techniques
to try to understand what are these
individual neurons encoding what are the
kinematic features of their code and I
can bore you with bar graphs that are
you know 18 parameters long and
um and so I was we were just boring
ourselves with all of this data and Reza
shadmer came and visited and he has been
at the Forefront of thinking about
populations of purkinje neurons sort of
conspiring to generate comprehensive
codes at the population level and he
said well why don't you just see what
they're all doing if you'll you know mix
them up and so we did we we combined all
of these neural recordings together and
what we found was really remarkable
given what we had observed in the
interposed nucleus which to remind you
was a linear scaling of the increase in
activity with the magnitude of the
decrease and it's scaled with Peak
velocity so what we observed in the
purkinje neurons which are here sorted
by Peak velocity is that there was a net
decrease in the activity of the
population of purkinje neurons that also
scaled in magnitude relative to Peak
velocity so the largest pauses were
happening with the very fastest reaches
and it um it sort of scales linearly so
if we if we sort of match that that
magnitude of a of a pause if you will
onto the scaled activity of the
interposed nucleus it
stands to raise reason that this
disinhibition may may sort of regulate
the amplitude of the activity that's
coming out of the interposed nucleus
okay so that was a lot but I hope that
that you followed all that so I showed
you now what purkinje neurons are doing
but I I started this section with this
question of how this computation might
be made
um and so I need to kind of take a
little detour into teaching you a little
bit more about cerebellar theory in
order to get here before I do that I
want to point out two temporal
relationships that emerge from these
data the first is that the the max
outward acceleration Peak velocity those
are parameters in kinematic space that
happened before
deceleration okay that's kind of obvious
the um the reach kinematics have a
bell-shaped profile so they you know
accelerate then D cell right to end
point
um but also in patients with cerebellar
damage the timing
of agonists and breaking antagonist
muscles that's seen in healthy patients
is delayed in in in cerebellar patients
so there's there's some kind of a this
and then that relationship that emerges
in coordinated movements and so we
hypothesize that this peak velocity is
serving as something of a contextual cue
to the cerebellum to as then regulate
the amplitude of deceleration by the
structure
and so to expand on this idea that
there's an association between a this
and then that we're going to take a left
turn I'm going to remind people about
cerebellar associative learning and then
we're going to get back to reaching
so many people in their sort of
introductory Neuroscience classes will
learn about delay eyelid conditioning in
cerebellum at which point they'll fall
asleep and then they'll wake up again
when people are talking about cognition
but I'm going to beg for your attention
here
um so in delay eyelid conditioning
classic pavlovian sorts of pairings
there's a neutral condition stimulus in
this case it's a tone the tone is played
for several hundred milliseconds and at
the very end of the tone at puff is
delivered an air puff is delivered to
the eye this is an aversive stimulus
that causes a reflexive eye blink
in in naive animals after repeated
pairings of the tone and the puff the
tone and the puff the tone and the puff
the animal learns to close his eyelid
just before the puff is about to come
okay so you can see that there's this
learned component to anticipating the
time of the of the air puff now one
critical piece of this associative
learning is that there's a Time
component to it so the animal does not
close its eye at the beginning of the
tone it closes its eyelid right before
the puff is going to happen
and so
neuroscientists like Mike Mock and Dean
bonamano have thought deeply about how
it is that this timing can be learned I
should also add that Decades of work
show that this this task require was
required requires the cerebellum so we
think this is actually happening within
the cerebellum but the basic upshot is
that the mossy fiber inputs to the
cerebellum carry this tone activity and
that granule cells break that invariant
tone activity up into what is called a
temporal basis set so there's sort of
chunks of time that are represented by
small populations of granule cells each
one of those populations converges onto
a purkinje neuron which under the naive
condition isn't doing anything except
inhibiting the nuclei and so there's no
Behavior
so what happens in the in the presence
of a puff of air is that there is
activity
um that is uh generated in what is
called the inferior Olive which is a
teaching signal to the cerebellum
details alighted the point is is that
when this teaching signal happens there
is a concomitant change in the strength
of a granule cell inputs to purkinje
neurons but only in the cells that were
active right before the puff okay so
this is how time it might then be sort
of associated with an aversive event
that that redu reduction in synaptic
strength leads to pauses and purkinje
cells and common concomitant
disinhibition of the cerebellar nuclei
and then that leads to the conditioned
response so we hypothesize that this
activity that we see during reaching
movements in the interposed nucleus is
akin to a conditioned response that is
it's responding to some sort of initial
cue
what does this have to do with reach
adaptation right so I showed you these
uh these velocity traces of the reaching
movement this bell-shaped velocity
profile and so we would argue that let's
say that this is going to be a bad reach
it's going to overshoot its Target so we
have uh this uh these this initial
kinematic information coming into the
cerebellum through the mossy fiber
pathway if it overshoots its Target
maybe there's a complex Spike that
complex Spike then is going to go to the
purkinje neurons change the synaptic
weights of the granule cells that were
active during that sort of peak velocity
phase
then when this um reach happens again
the same people or the same Peak
velocity may be reached but because of
this associative plasticity we think
that there may be an increase in the
activity of the nuclear neurons to sort
of Drive reach slowing to increase the
rate of deceleration and land on target
so that's our working hypothesis how on
Earth do we test any of this so one of
the tricks of the delay eyelid
conditioning field is to substitute the
conditioned stimulus with electrical or
optogenetic stimulation of Mossy fiber
pathway directly so this way you get you
get around of all the other stuff going
on in the brain and you just introduce
the stimulus here
um and you can fictively associate those
things in in rabbits we don't have that
luxury because we're looking at this
naturalistic movement but we borrowed a
sort of trick from them and so instead
of um
uh perturbing a reach through some sort
of external means we're going to
perturbia reach through activation of
the mossy fiber Pathways themselves so
we're essentially superimposing some
kind of Novel contextual input into the
into the circuit and so to do this we
introduced a channel adoption into the
pontine nucleus of the of the mouse
which expresses then Channel adoption in
the mossy fibers very densely you can
then implant optical fiber
and then perform an experiment that's
conceptually similar to the ones I
showed you in the interposed nucleus
where we stimulate in closed loop with
the movement okay in this case we're um
we're stimulating
um slightly differently because we're
going to do this in a block format so
rather than stimulating and randomized
uh ways we're going to stimulate such
that the animal can actually
hope to learn that every reach it gets
this perturbation so also work from
Adam's Hamptons lab has shown that
stimulation of the pontine fibers can
perturb the reach so we had good reason
to think that there might be some kind
of a learnable contingency here
so indeed um we found that optogenetic
activation of the pontine afferents
caused overshoot of the reaching
movement
however if we continuously deliver that
stimulus the effect of that stimulus
actually adapts so there's less of a of
a kinematic effect late in the stimulus
block compared to early and when we turn
off the stimulus we see that there's
this opposite overshoon this is a
classic Hallmark of cerebellar
adaptation so this is cool now we've got
an adaptation Paradigm that we can use
to explore this this idea that readapts
so we saw that in in all animals that
we've tested we know that activation of
these cell of these afferents actually
causes changes in purkinje cells but
what happens during that within session
adaptation
so to address this we've now recorded
from purkinje neurons during adaptation
skipping over some details neurons well
I I don't have to sometimes neurons are
activated by this stimulus and other
neurons are inhibited sort of similar to
that kind of balance of uh bursters and
positives that I showed you about
earlier
and so we grouped cells either they were
activated by stimulation or inactivated
by stimulation and watched how that
progressed through the course of
adaptation
and what we found is that neurons that
showed an activation to
um in response to optogenetic
stimulation or inactivation and response
slowly Decay back to essentially
Baseline so if we look at p-value Maps
we find that there's a very high
difference between the stimulated and
control
profiles of purkinje neurons early in
the stimulation block and that decays
with with multiple trials over the
course of the block
and so this is very cool this is within
within session adaptation and it brings
us uh to a question of like how is this
how is this happening so I'm not going
to go uh into much of the details of
this model but we hypothesize
um a sort of a consistent with the mock
and bonam motto uh work that there's a
Time varying population of granule cells
active during the reach and that our
octogenetic perturbation is driving
activity within this population which is
then uh sort of decaying back to its
Target Zone during
um during adaptation
so it's interesting if we if we look at
which synapses are actually undergoing
change during this this adaptation block
we find that of course the this the um
granul cells that we're driving with our
optogenetics they're changing so their
weights are decayed but what's important
to note is that neurons that we are not
explicitly uh driving are also changing
but in this way that's temporally locked
to the stimulus and we think that this
um sort of
um uh application of at of plasticity to
neurons that weren't causing the problem
but we're sort of just coincidentally
active during the perturbation is
essential for the emergence of after
effects that are considered to be the
Hallmark of learning but we consider
them to be evidence that there's a
misattribution of error to the
coincidentally active cells
so I'll end there to summarize that we
think that we have at least the
beginnings of a um of a model for feed
forward control during a volitional
movement uh in the cerebellum and that
um through our experiments we have an
idea that there may be a conditioned
response in the nucleus that's
structuring Precision of endpoint that
may be learned by the population
activity in purkinje cells and that that
is sort of temporally produced through
what we think is happening as a is a
basis that is forming in response to
naturalistic inputs which I didn't get
into
so I want to thank the very wonderful
people I get to work with Matt Becker
and Dylan Callum most notably for this
talk and with that I'm happy to take any
questions so I realize it went fast
[Applause]
um thanks so much for the great talk uh
we have few minutes for audience
questions
thank you Abby I really enjoyed that
talk
um any this is just a detailed question
any idea what mechanism is responsible
for sort of Staggering the delays of
these cells yeah yeah we have a lot of
ideas about that actually so
um so I actually have a figure from a
manuscript that um that is on bioarchive
now that is explicitly about this topic
topic how does a base how would a
temporal basis set form in the granule
cell layer
um so this idea has has stumped the um
the people that are studying the the lay
Island conditioning because what they
have is an invariant signal coming in
and so they hypothesize that there's
recurrent and efficient and there's all
these kinds of specialized mechanisms in
the granular solar itself
so my my student Jesse Gilmer whose work
I didn't talk about he was building some
models and he showed this one figure and
it had this basis set and I was like
where did that come from he's like oh I
just put in some you know naturalistic
inputs and so this this was surprising
because I don't think that the people
studying the naturalistic movements had
really engaged with the timing problem
but it turns out if you have time
varying inputs in the mossy fibers which
we model as
um Ornstein ulenbeck functions that have
an autocorrelation time of about 100
milliseconds sort of similar to the
activity of Mossy fiber afferents if you
put that structure of of input into a
very simple model of a summation circuit
in the granule cell area where each
granule cell receives four of these
these sort of noisy inputs that this
basis set is just an emergent property
it's actually very trivial for the
granule cell layer to generate this it
requires is a level of inhibition that
can that can float with this but that's
very consistent with the interneuron
network of Golgi cells in the cerebellar
cortex so we think this is a highly
likely thing to happen
in electric fish that's right so they
they have
um uh so in the Kennedy paper from um in
Anne Kennedy's paper from Nate sawtell's
lab they have this nice basis set that
they have observed in fish granule cells
which is probably the clearest basis set
that anyone has in a granule Solaire in
a cerebellar-like structure so with
their um their at least when I've talked
to Nate I think that they think that
there's a because those um electrical
organ discharges are quite pulsatile
they think that there's a special neuron
called a unipolar brush shell that's
sort of extending the duration of that
pulsatile length signal which we think
is slightly different than this kind of
continuous
motor signal that might be motor and
sensory sort of reaffirence signal that
would be coming into the cerebellum
through the mossy fibers
um but it's a very it's a very good
point
um so right
um we've talked about it with the post
docson students earlier today about how
the there's really a dearth of um uh
population recordings in granule cells
um at the millisecond time scales that
are really needed to interrogate this
idea so
um so I have a question so we actually
had a donut Club on a few of your papers
and one of the questions that came up
was
um some of these principles of
computations that you see for movement
in the cerebellum how do you think they
may generalize to sort of cognitive
computations
um that happen in the cerebellum but may
not necessarily be related to movement
yeah it's such a good question it's
really the question of the hour and I
think with Sheldon's talk that the um
the idea I think would be that there's
sort of um an expansion of prefrontal
cortices along with the actual anterior
actually posterior and lateral uh
components of the cerebellum and those
have evolutionarily grown together and
so I think it's a very fair question and
I I can only wildly speculate and it's
probably completely wrong but mate we
know that there's some heterogeneity in
the circuit elements that are seen in
the granule cell layer in different
lobules so for example I brought up
these unipolar brush cells that that
Nate Sawtell has has sort of speculated
about those are found very densely and
vestibular components and I don't know
whether they're seen in the um more sort
of
uh posterior lateral section segments
but you might expect that time constants
of autocorrelation are getting longer
and longer and that if the plasticity
mechanisms in cerebellum can keep up I
think there's an eligibility Trace
question and maybe Jeff can sort of
Enlighten us here but but you know if if
the if the reverberation throughout the
brain is robust enough to consistently
reactivate the same kinds of cells in
the same cells then maybe there can be
essentially an the same algorithm about
error and and
Association of
um sort of predictors to that that
happens in the motor regions just at
longer time scales so I think it's all
about time scale it's all about
can you get a longer basis set are the
eligibility traces for the plasticity
that's required for change sufficient
for for this
um so I don't know that's that's kind of
him we're giving in probably not very
satisfying but yeah it's a great it's a
very interesting set of questions
thanks thanks so much uh are there any
more questions from the audience
I can ask one more sort of high level
question so I'd like on a lot of us are
thinking about you know how to adapt the
existing theories in various domains to
capture more and more complex Behavior
so in and it's becoming increasingly
possible to sort of measure more
accurately complex behavior and movement
like higher degree of Freedom movements
in animals and movement across longer
time scales and naturalistic
environments so in what ways do you
think sort of these theories and
principles say in the cerebellum would
need to be adapted or would it just be
more of the same when you're trying to
explain complex Behavior or would they
need to fundamentally change to explain
sort of more complex Behavior
yeah I don't know I mean I think
fundamentally you have to have sharp
questions other other ways you're lost
right so I I think that
um we can talk about more complex
Behavior but what what about more
complex Behavior are we talking about
right is it the complexity itself is it
you know something else
um already our behavior is considered
absurdly complex so you know different
audiences are like oh my God
unconstrained reaching are you kidding
me right so I mean people that study
motor control want a two you know a
plane or two armed robot that's it you
know so I think that we're making track
I think we have some traction on this
behavior and it's already complex and I
think that people can make Headway on
much more complex tasks if they're if
their questions are clear it's just a
matter of like what are you what do you
want to know right so thanks
[Applause]